they have
won enough to be in the mix and looking
to continue that march to the postseason
here today as tommy edmond climbs into
the batter's box and brandon woodruff
first pitch edmond right back to woody
one pitch one out that's how the day
begins
one away quickly here is paul deyoung
swinging a miss struck him at blew him
away at 98 on the 16th day of september
the pitch
got him looking and gold schmidt knew it
right on the outside corner again
woodruff goes to number one at 97. no
balls two strikes to kesten hero
and there's a drive deep left field and
that is gone a no doubter for kesten
hera as the brewers grab an early
two-nothing lead
the brewer's starting to
score early in games last couple of days
and a two spot kessinger is starting to
feel it again a blast into the cardinals
bullpen it's five up five down for
woodruff tyler o'neill hitting 189 five
homers he's driven in 13.
and o'neil lifts a high fly ball into
deep right center field at the wall
goodbye that is a long home run into
right center field tyler o'neal
sixth home run of the year and the
cardinals get on the board their first
hit of the afternoon to cut the lead to
two to one just when you think he's not
going to catch up to a fastball well
two down and justin williams with his
cardinal debut
justin williams base head into right
field
justin williams with his first
all right justin williams a long time
comment
two-strike pitch
and goes off of woodruff kick save and a
beauty right to jed jericho that's too
easy to pass up that will mean on the
3-2 count that the runner
garcia will be taking off from first
base the cardinals have three infielders
on the left side of the diamond what
does adam throw here on three and two i
think he's gonna get uncle charlie or
maybe the cutter the fourth choice is a
fastball swing and a miss he struck him
out so he didn't want the cutter didn't
want the curveball and he came back with
a fastball
and that was the pitch that hira hit out
in the first wainwright challenges him
in the third and gets his man they've
had more trouble getting runners home no
questions with less than two outs than
any time i've ever seen outfield is
straight away runners hit second and
third nobody out here in the top of the
fourth
and carpenter lifts a fly ball out to
shallow right it may drop
gamble there to make the catch gold
schmidt was about halfway and he's back
to the bag at third
second and third and one out tyler
o'neil at the plate
and o'neill hits a high fly ball into
right gammel over he'll make the catch
goldsmith will tag up
the run will score and we're tied at 2-2
tyler o'neill is driven in two that's
what i'm talking about right there
stay inside the ball make sure that you
put it into play
and actually get it out of the way get
it over with do it early especially when
it's the tying run doesn't try to pull
this ball he just tries to stay on it
basketball is grounded to the left side
he jammed it
really well carpenter up with it and he
throws out gammel so a very good inning
for wainwright two weak hit ground balls
and a strikeout two balls in one strike
yachty's so adept and going the other
way
and pulls it to the third baseman
peterson
and vader hustling on the play
he was running
and jerko was going to try to throw him
out didn't matter peterson
got yachty and vader was hustling anyway
so rudder at third infield in and here's
tommy edmond the o2 pitch
hits it the other way that's a base hit
the cardinals have the lead vader will
score edmond on his way to second edmond
will stop there
the double on the 02 pitch hit it the
other way 3-2 saint louis
let's see if yell it's going to stay hot
tying around at second go ahead run over
at first two runners aboard for
milwaukee they're batting in the fifth
inning trailing by one pitch from
wainwright is grounded to the right side
and tommy edmond has it and he throws
out yelich good work adam wainwright he
gets yelich to bounce out to end the
fifth there's brad miller
and a bloop double back in the fourth
and he hits one a ton into center at the
wall gone
brad miller launched that baby into
center
solo home run for miller his seventh of
the year
and the cardinals have a 4-2 lead he
really hit that ball hard straightaway
center field we've seen this from miller
before and again it's a hanging
change-up so adam wright will try to
finish this one off four to two we're in
the bottom of the seventh eye level
changing all over the place in that
at-bat same breaking ball different
heights
eight strikeouts adam wainwright the
two-two
sway and a miss unbelievable adam
wainwright goes the distance and he's
getting better with age